tell me what you're doing here today
today i'm going to determine who's going
to be marketable for modeling in the
fashion industry
how do you measure someone's
attractiveness i've been scouting models
for
several decades now i'm going to be
looking at height first size second
not are they good looking everybody's
good looking
in their own way everybody's good
looking
in their own way no
that's the exact opposite get over there
and hit your mark
give us a spin nobody comes out wearing
that outfit and isn't trying to show off
and make sure that
everybody sees her howdy tell me all
about you
i'm 37 i'm single currently i'm a
bartender
um but i've have like an extensive i.t
background
i like football i like beer
he said it i was like yup you said
barton i was like
beer i know it's one of those things
where it feels like one of the boring
first date questions where he's like
what else can i say uh i like beer
i like nachos all of these things i
probably would have guessed
just by taking a look at him i would put
him at a five with a little bit of work
he might be able to get
some background work yeah you'll never
be a main character but as a secondary
character maybe fodder
someone who dies in the first chapter
for sure would you like to work
somebody's got to be an extra you're an
extra you got the face of somebody that
no one's ever going to remember but
that's honest
that is honest i wonder if people are
going to be more receptive to this guy's
advice than the black woman i think
they're going to be receptive more
receptive to his
yeah because of the way he says it also
how he looks
yes you know a decent looking gay man
who's all well-dressed and does that as
this way gets a lot more reception than
a
older lady black woman who's just direct
even though the advice is
just as blunt who says it matters but
i'm like
if the advice works who cares how's it
going that's a yes
that works have you ever walked on a
runway no
now is a good time to start ready go
excellent shoulders back that's fashion
oh no
no it's western
is he trying to sell me a car oh my god
show business
i know what it was but that was that was
crazy he's clearly a showman this is
what he's used to doing he's
used to having a public persona yeah
that's fascinating
yeah you know what makes me think of
certain whackers who do these weird
positions
yes you know what i'm about yeah have
you ever worked in the fashion
industry nope never even tried not not
not really that height that size the
muscle tone broad shoulders small
waist long legs because everything is
pretty much symmetrical i wouldn't
really lose any weight
yeah i'd give him a 10. absolutely
somebody would book him
hi there hi how old are you 26. what's
your name tyler
he's talking to him like he's cute hi
how are you what's your name oh you're
so cute
what's your name would you like lollipop
tyler yeah black lives matter cool
yeah that's what it really feels like
you do have a great face those big giant
brown eyes
i like that you got the scruff going on
i would say if you were going to get
into this industry you would need to
grow a little bit taller
especially with the hair it's a little
bit on the severe side the hair is a bit
on the severe side
that's harsh it's a very interesting use
of severe
side i mean you mean black hair
is that what you're saying my hair is
too coarse for you
too natural
for your privilege white man is that
what you're saying
huh you probably want to touch my hair
too
huh yeah i think he's basically just
saying that hairstyle she's not going to
work in the fashion industry
so i would say just because of the
height book ability market factor is
going to be at about a four
what about appearance-wise
appearance-wise with that smile that
energetic laugh and just the magnetism
yeah yeah i'm sure you're a magnet i'm
sure you get some
single married single not for long
you'll be fine great
not for that because why because why i'm
here because you know
that's show business you know what it's
crazy how i got away that it's almost
like
you know when you reject a girl and
she's like what's wrong it's like don't
worry you're going to find someone soon
girls hate this
but because of his charisma it's just
like you know
it's like when you reject a girl like
anyone would be so lucky to be with you
but with him the way he says it sounds
good i want to be able to say that you
know
i want to be able to say it's not you
it's me and half people be like oh thank
you
that would be nice for once you know you
just have to change one little thing you
just have to say it
it's absolutely i
hi what's your name i'm joanna have you
ever tried to get into this industry
i have not no in this industry because
of your hype that's going to be the
first thing that's going to take you
down
but the size is great measurements look
good you're petite we
we don't say short she's fun-sized you
know without a margie
yeah but he knows how to say things in a
way that you accept even though it's
still harsh yeah
no she's not small she's fun size you're
fun i think if you were going to get
into modeling sure
change up the hair color can i see you
without the eyeglasses
excellent if i was going to rate her
based on whether or not she would get
booked in this industry it's going to be
on the lower side yeah i'd probably put
you at around a four on marketability
for getting booked on jobs do i think
she's adorable and pretty and has a
great smile yeah when she smiles you
definitely light up the room you seem
like you're the girl that goes i like
green hair i'm going to have it whether
you like it or not yeah
excellent hi she's one of those girls
that when she walks into a room with a
big old smile
you automatically will like them not
sure about the harajuku hair
right on the money bee that was harajuku
no little girl japanese girl
you know and you know the ones that cry
like this
yeah the little dolls yeah
yeah that's what it is under all these
layers she thick
she looks like a kind of girl who's
never been to a library but dresses like
a librarian yeah
i never understood those people you know
those people who like i love chai latte
and keep lots of plants in their place
but you know they got plan b beside the
drawer like
it's an interesting combination
[Laughter]
you know what i mean i like it safe but
adventurous
yeah but other than that she's got a
good little look to her
hi hi there if he came into the agency
on a scouting day
chances are i would select him this is a
guy that you would see
in a calvin klein fashion show walking
down the runway and nothing more than
just a speedo
let's take a look and see how your walk
is and then we can determine whether or
not maybe a runway might be a good thing
for you
can you smile okay there's a lot of work
to be done
you know what it reminds me of it's the
first day of military when people have
to march and there's always that one
[ __ ] that bear marching
the one yeah with the same harmony same
arm say like bear marching that's what
they called it
private atlas stop bear marching you
always hear something like that
yeah that's what he looked like seeing
that as well and then he told his smile
and he smiles like can you smile
peter it's it's a school photo shoot
please can you smile
peter your family's gonna see this peter
are you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i remember school photo shoots there's
always that one kid who knows
i used to like looking back at those
photo albums because there's always kids
who just didn't listen
yeah there was always girls who were
like ready to do it but there was always
a couple of voices like
already they got the ponyta yeah they
got the
you know taking pictures was not they
think no the girls
ponytails like smile
they were all night long you know these
they spend their time
tomorrow it's picture day it's gonna be
awesome oh sorry and you spent the whole
night
okay i'm gonna look like this
but guys that's not her thing
super scary with it that it it and it it
transpires whenever you have dating
lamps
dating apps the guys they look the same
that they did
no but the bathroom selfie instead so
they got the dirty ass mirror
update picture let's take a look and see
how your walk is and then we can
determine whether or not maybe a runway
might be a good thing for you
can you smile okay a lot of work to do
on him for a runway
i mean listen if we lost the pajama
pants and the extra large jacket on him
he could absolutely go out to clients
with a good haircut what you heard was
i i i could get some work he's going to
hire me
what i heard was your haircut's trash
your pants got to go
and you need to do a lot of work in
order to walk
to walk but that's my drip and i love it
so
what you think and that's fashion
[Laughter]
i love myself so it doesn't matter yeah
i can tell you love yourself
i don't care what anyone thinks it shows
her roasts were way better a1
yeah yeah but he's not trying to roast
no he's trying to be nice you're going
to be an easy one because you're already
adorable
high cheekbones nice good skin smile for
me
yeah great teeth you're definitely curvy
in the hips measurement
okay can you go ahead and spin around
for me some people have those curves and
they're not quite sure what to do with
them
okay if i was going to get you into
modeling i would say let's take out the
piercing
go for the big curls keep everything
great on the face
i don't mind the scar everything can be
taken care of through photoshop
but you want a number of what's
marketable i'd easily just say five it's
not too high it's not too low you would
definitely be able to work in the petit
market in a certain city
but no piercing yo same advice as the
other girl she said the same thing
everyone got so defensive when she said
you notice a difference maybe it's
delivery maybe it's who it says it but i
did like the interesting uh differences
and some people think like these people
are being [ __ ] it's just like no
it's it's an industry they're making
money
so they have to be super objective it's
not about everyone looks beautiful no
objectively
when it comes to this kind of work some
people are just better suited good
yeah yeah but yeah it is what it is it's
also the appearance
if you judge me and i know that you
should it's not it matters for you who
says it not
let me rephrase that yeah if most people
would get judged
yeah it wouldn't matter okay it wouldn't
matter because people would look at
yeah but okay who the [ __ ] are you to
judge me yeah what are you yeah
yeah your car is trash what's your car
all right you take the bus
all right deuces you know what i mean
that kind of so
yeah people judging is like but
you know i get it but you know like it's
like this let's say if you worked in the
fitness industry or you're trying to get
in shape
maybe an old man comes to you like hey
you're doing the deadlift rock you might
like you talk about old man but who
knows what he used to do
old man could have been a bodybuilder
back in the day right so
it's important not to just throw out the
source just because they don't appear to
have the success that you think that
you'd want
but it's also okay to be skeptical they
did this test whether it was
someone i was doing fitness i was
deeming fitness classes but that person
was not fit right
and people had opinions right yeah they
had opinions
you don't know who the person is right
right right so that's just something to
keep in mind but uh
but yeah that's pretty much all i had in
terms of thoughts funny video and uh
yeah
tell us what you guys think what do you
guys rate yourselves let's see if you're
going to be honest
yeah where my fixes at where am i six
at from the front to back
[Music]
oh